See,
I really liked the psycho analyst and
I liked the idea that you have a psyche
that's inside of you and that that is
structured in partly consciously and in
part conch unconsciously.
There's something about that that's really
cool and I've learned a lot from the
psychoanalyst,
but you know,
there is a funny consequence of thinking
the way they think and you do think the
way they think,
even if you don't know it.
Like we tend to think that a
lot of us is inside our head.
You know,
that's the psyche model basically.
But the more I've practiced
as a clinical psychologist,
the last,
I've actually been
convinced that that's true.
So I could say,
well,
let's say I want to know
about your personality.
We think,
well,
I want to know you.
I want to know about your subjectivity.
I didn't want to know
what's inside of you,
but that isn't actually what you do.
Want to know if,
if,
if you're doing clinical work,
say with someone you want to know,
did they have any friends?
That's really important because if you're
miserable and anxious and badly placed
in life and misbehaving,
one of the reasons that all of that
can occur is because you don't have any
friends.
You don't know anyone,
and that's not something
that's inside you.
It's,
it's you localized in a broader sphere.
And then you might say,
well,
do you have job?
And while let's talk about the job,
do you actually make
enough money with your job?
Is it satisfying for you in any way?
Are you bullied all the time?
When you're at work?
Does it provoke anxiety?
Is it a career that allows
you to go somewhere?
Are you overworked?
Well,
but let's start with
just the first question.
Do you have a job?
Well,
if the answer to that is no,
you have a serious problem
and that would enough,
might be too depressed you and make you
anxious and hopeless and nihilistic and
all of those things.
And you could say,
well,
you're not reacting very
well to not having a job.
But that's kind of a foolish objection.
Even though some of it might be true.
One problem is,
is that you're not reacting
very well to not having a job,
but in other problem is that you don't
have a job and that actually constitutes
a problem,
right?
You don't get to eat.
You don't have a place to live.
So those aren't psychological problems.
Precisely.
Even though a psychological
problem could make it worse.
Well are you as educated as you should be?
That's another question.
How do you handle drugs and alcohol?
Are they taking you down a bad pathway?
You know?
Um,
what about intimate relationships?
We have one,
you have a plan for one or they,
is that a never ending series of
catastrophes or something that you avoid
completely.
That's a big problem.
And maybe people don't,
aren't attracted to you
for one reason or another.
And you could think about that
as a psychological problem,
but it's an interpersonal problem.
And the degree to which that's
a psychological problem is,
is certainly an specified when you
first begin to talk to somebody.
What about your family?
Do you have a family?
Cause it's hard to be in
the world all by yourself,
that's for sure.
It makes things a lot more stressful.
Even though having a family can
also be extraordinarily stressful.
I mean,
don't do you have plans to have children?
How are you doing with your parents?
Do you get along with your siblings?
You know,
all of that.
All of that to me is more
fundamental and it's outside of you.
Those are elements of your experience
more broadly conceptualized more than they
are objects of your psychology
or of your internal experience.
You know,
it's sort of like
while a person is,
uh,
is it is a creature that exists
at multiple levels of analysis,
right?
Something might go wrong
with you at a cellular level,
so maybe you're born with
a genetic abnormality,
so something's wrong with you molecularly
or you have something wrong with a
major organ.
Or maybe there's something
wrong with you psychologically,
or maybe you're in a pathological family
or maybe you're stuck in a pathological
social system and figuring out what's,
why you're suffering means going
up and down those different levels.
Trying to specify the appropriate level
for analysis and also the appropriate
level for intervention.
And for me as a,
as I've said,
even though I'm a great admirer of the
psychoanalysts and I do things like dream
analysis,
which I really find you an incredibly
useful and enlightening the first,
the fundamental level of analysis is,
well,
what's your experience structured like?
Exactly.
And that isn't localized in you.
Now the behaviorists do that too because
it's one of the things I really liked
about the behavioral
approach to psychotherapy.
It's very,
very concrete and practical.
It's like they'll say,
well,
there are certain things that you need
to have in order to live properly and
maybe you don't have the skills or the
wherewithal wherewithal to accumulate
them and we'll break them down into
tiny little pieces and you'll practice.
So for example,
with someone who doesn't have any friends,
then you do a micro analysis
of their social skills,
say and maybe an analysis of the kinds
of anxiety that are stopping them from
going out and meeting people.
And then you address those
things practically one by one.
You tried to get the person
to have some friends.
He tried to figure out how they can
establish an intimate relationship.
You see if you can help
them sort out their family,
you do what you can
about their employment.
And a lot of that's only tangentially
related to really in some sense to the
structure of their psyche.
But one of the things you'll see if you
work as a clinician or as a counselor is
that most of the time people come and
see you because they have problems,
not because they have
psychological problems and
those things are not that easy
to distinguish.
You know,
it's sort of the psychoanalytic idea,
sort of like,
well,
if you just start your act together,
everything would work out for you.
It's like,
yeah,
there's some truth in that,
but
okay.
But you know,
if you're 55 years old and
you've just been laid off work,
okay,
and maybe through no fault of your own,
yeah,
it isn't obvious how much
getting your act together,
it's going to help you find
another job because the,
the actual problem that you're facing
me have relatively to do with you.
And that would especially be the case if
you're maybe on the bottom half of the
intelligence distribution for example.
And so it isn't as easy for you just
to go out and pick up new skills at the
drop of a hat,
you know?
And that gets harder as you get older
because your Iq actually declines quite
substantially as you get older.
The working or the the fluid
intelligence part anyways,
exercise can keep that at bay,
by the way.
It's the best way to keep that at bay.